just as I was reaching the finishing
pages of this epic 168 page report on
GPT Vision which showcased unexpected
abilities novel use cases and
predictions for the future Google
dropped their colossal RTX Endeavor and
the data Google used with over 500
skills and 150,000 tasks is open- Source
I've picked out over 75 highlights from
both papers which I read in full and
I'll also bring in an exclusive report
from the information to give us an idea
of what is next by the end of the video
I want you to have a great sense for
what GPT with vision can do today and a
more acute awareness of what is coming
in Vision Video and Robotics tomorrow
but let's start with this Google
deepmind report released just a few
hours ago essentially what it showed is
that you could create a general purpose
robot from data from diverse robotic
tasks these were data sets from
different universities on different
continents and Google wanted to see if
this diverse data could improve their
famous rt2 model I talked a lot more
about rt2 in the video you can see on
screen but essentially it was trained on
web data as well as robotics data that
meant that it could understand questions
like pick up the extinct animal but the
RTX series is another step up even
though it comes just 2 months later the
report highlighted that conventionally
robotic learning methods train a
separate model for every application
every robot and even every environment
their big finding was that training a
single model on that diverse data Ena
that robot to outperform even the
specialist robots the improved version
of rt1 became rt1 X and rt2 became RT 2x
but here you can see rt1 X Out competing
specialist models weirdly aside from
this wiping robot at Berkeley in a range
of domains you've got kitchen
manipulation cable rout door opening and
many more tasks that I'll get to in a
second the paper even demonstrated
applicability to robot arms and even
quadrupeds think four-legged doglike
robots and here you can see how it
improved rt2 which was already a big
Improvement on rt1 and as Google says
our results suggest that co-training
with data from other platforms imbus rt2
x with additional skills that were not
present in the original data set
enabling it to perform novel tasks
apparently it couldn't do things like
this before move the Apple between the
can and the orange or move the Apple
near but not on top of the cloth or move
the apple on top of the pot this gives
you a taste of the kind of skills they
Incorporated picking moving pushing
placing sliding putting navigating
separating pointing and on and on I like
that at the end we have assembling and
turning on the paper draws the analogy
with large language models that are
trained on massive webscale Text data
and those models tend to outperform
systems that are only trained on narrow
task specific data sets well same thing
now with robotics that's why I call this
the gpt2 moment for Robotics and the
paper says even if such robotic data
sets in their current size and coverage
are insufficient to attain the
impressive generalization results that
have been demonstrated by llms that's
large language models in the future the
union of such data can potentially
provide this kind of coverage one way to
put it would be to think of how General
and multikill gp4 is in language from
coding to poetry and Mathematics and
more now imagine that but with robotic
skills now one question you might have
is how would data on folding clothes
help with pushing an apple well they say
that unlike most prior works we directly
train our policy on all of this x
embodiment data without any mechanisms
to reduce the embodiment Gap they didn't
try any big translation between domains
or breaking down the problem into sub
aspects they did however put the input
image data into a common resolution and
UniFi the action vectors across these
seven dimensions now that 55 billion
parameter number and the fact that it
comes from the P model that's underg
ging rt2 X is the perfect segue to GPT
Vision after all open AI directly
compared their GPT 4 Vision model to p
17 billion which was a precursor model
to p x and you might notice that at
least for visual question answering the
P model that's the precursor 17 billion
parameter model outperformed GPT 4
Vision so everything you're about to see
from the 168 page gp4 vision report
actually represents the lower bound of
current Frontier capability to recap
that's gp4 Vision being beaten by P 17
billion parameters which is beaten by p
x 55 billion parameters which has now
been incorporated into rt2 the robot and
all of that is not even to bring in open
aai GOI model or Google Gemini which
I'll talk about later so the main focus
of the video the dawn of large
multimodal models a huge 160 plus page
report from Microsoft it was released
just a few days ago and to be honest
could constitute an entire video on its
own but I'm going to give you all of the
highlights here in this video so please
do leave a like or subscribe if you find
it helpful for all of the fascinating
demos you're about to see Microsoft says
that they carefully controlled both the
images and text to prevent them from
being seen during GPT 4V training the
images were either not accessible online
or had a timestamp Beyond April 2023
their headline finding was that GPT
Vision shows impressive human level
capabilities across many of the
experimented domains but honestly they
were really really ambitious they wanted
to show business use cases they
introduced a whole new way of prompting
called visual prompting I mean to be
honest they call it visual referring
prompting and they try to make that
stick but I'm just going to call it
visual prompting and by the end they're
proposing agent structures and testing
for self- consistency it gets pretty
wild but it's time for the first demo
they showed GPT Vision this table with
the drinks that they had ordered and
they took a photo of the menu they asked
how much should I pay for the beer on
the table according to the price on the
menu and GPT Vision got it we're
starting a little slow here but imagine
you're drunk on the beach and you don't
even know what you've ordered this could
be useful next was GPT Vision putting
the information from a driver's license
into Json format now first time round it
wasn't perfect listing his hair color as
non-applicable when the license says
brown but there are ways to improve
performance as we'll see later in fact
the first way of improving performance
is right now that's using Chain of
Thought Chain of Thought is basically a
way of getting the model to put out its
intermediate reasoning Often by using a
phrase like let's think step by step as
you can see here the first time it
couldn't identify that there's 11 apples
and actually even when they used let's
think step by step it still got it wrong
what about let's count the apples row by
row nope it got the right final answer
but got the rows mixed up they tried
some other prompts but finally settled
on this one you are an expert en
counting things in the image and this
time it got it right now all those new
methods you've been seeing like llms as
prompt optimizers or prompt breeder it
looks like they are going to be equally
applicable to GPT Vision in fact after
that example they say that throughout
the paper we're going to employ that
technique of calling it an expert across
various scenarios for better performance
but here is one of the big Revelations
from the paper for me the paper says
that this particular ability isn't seen
in existing models and that is being
able to follow pointers that might be
circles squares or even arrows drawn on
a diagram and the amazing thing is this
seems to work better than giving GPT
Vision coordinates the researchers from
Microsoft Drew these arrows onto the
photo putting the label object one and
object two and gbt vision analyzes those
objects perfectly but there was
something that I noticed which is that
technically the Green Arrow is pointing
to the pavement and the red arrow is
pointing to the table I should say that
the arrows end at those places and
instead of interpreting the literal end
of the arrows it
what the human meant it meant the
nearest big object the glass bottle and
the beer I know that's something small
but I find that really impressive the
next big finding was that in context F
shot learning is still really crucial
even for vision models in context means
as part of the prompt not in the
pre-training and fuse shot just means
giving a few examples before you ask
your key question and the proof of
concept examples that you're about to
see they say vividly demonstrate the
rising significance of in context few
shot learning for achieving improved
performance with large multimodal models
I'm going to speed through this example
just so you get the G essentially they
asked it to read the speed on this speed
meter it gets it wrong and even when
they ask it to think step by step it
still gets it wrong then they gave it
instructions and it still got it wrong
they tried loads of things but it just
couldn't seem to do it even when they
gave it one example one shot it still
got it wrong you can see in the prompt
they gave a correct worked example and
then ask the question again but no it
said just passing 70 mph but finally two
shot with two worked examples it then
gets it right next they showed that the
model could recognize celebrities and
there was one particularly interesting
example of Jensen hang he's the CEO of
Nvidia which produces the gpus that went
into training GPT 4 Vision anyway it
could apparently recognize its own
ingredients saying he's likely holding a
GPU next they had it recognizing
landmarks even even if they were at
weird angles or at night it could
recognize dishes even if they had
toppings and condiments it also did
really pretty well in medical image
understanding identifying what was wrong
with this particular foot you can see it
also working with a CT scan of course
before we get too excited our old friend
Hallucination is still there it
described a bridge overpass that I
frankly can't see at all it skipped over
North Carolina entirely when asked about
the states shown on this map and it also
gets seemingly random numbers wrong take
this table where it noted down almost
every number correctly down to three
decimal places but then for some reason
the 15
m971 1880 became 15
m971
421 actually I've just noticed while
filming that that's the same ending as
the profit in the next column so maybe
there was a reason but it's still pretty
random point is you still can't fully
rely on the outputs and it seems to me
that in figure 36 there was a mistake
that even the researchers didn't notice
if I'm right that shows how pernicious
these mistakes can be the researchers
say that the model not only understands
the program in the given flowchart but
also translates the details to a python
code if you go to figure 36 you see this
flowchart and it was asked can you
translate the flowchart to a python code
you can see the flowchart and you can
see the code now obviously it's
impressive that it can even attempt to
do this but that code is dodgy taking a
string as input essentially a bunch of
letters instead of a floating Point
number now the goal was to print the
larger number and that's what GPT Vision
says in the explanation that it will do
but that input problem that I mentioned
means that it returned three when
comparing 3 with 20 the paper also
called this answer correct when
averaging these two numbers which comes
out to
76555 that rounds to
$765 not
$765 now you might say all of this is
pedantic but the errors keep coming the
paper says that in the bottom row of
figure 37 GPT Vision shows a clear
understanding of both x and y axis and
explains the key Insight presented in
the chart go to figure 37 and you get
this chart the key insight to me from
this chart is that publishing bad okay
or pretty good papers makes almost no
difference it's only when they get very
creative original and good that it makes
lots of impact on your career now GPT
Vision does say that publishing a bad
paper has little impact on your career
and a creative paper has significant
impact correct but then it says the
impact of the paper on a person's career
increases as the quality of the paper
improves now while that's technically
correct it misses the key Insight
basically a flatline and then a sudden
upward turn anyway loads of errors but
let's focus on the potential use cases
because we must remember that GPT vision
is still capable of things like like
this a guy on Twitter or X Daniel lit
said this I've been told GPT 4 with code
interpreter is good at math he was
taking the Mickey because the output is
this can you compute the 7th root of 3
to ^ of 7 now the 7eventh root is the
opposite of raising a number to the
power of seven so the answer should be
three but it said the 7th root of 3 to
the 7 is approximately 4.2 but then
someone else put that image into GPT
vision and said why is this tweet funny
and GPT Vision was able to pick up on
the humor the humor in this tweet arises
from the mathematical inconsistency the
question posed to gpc4 with code
interpreter asked for the 7th root of 3
to the 7 mathematically the 7th root of
3 to the 7 is simply three it corrected
its own error the in congruity between
the question and the answer creates a
comedic effect so it was not only able
to correct its error it was able to see
the humor in someone pointing that out
but then someone went even more meta
pacing this entire thing into GPT Vision
saying why is this analysis funny and
then GPT vision is able to summarize the
entire situation describing GPT 4 itself
as analyzing its own mistake the irony
lies in GPT 4 critiquing its own
incorrect answer I would have given it
bonus points if it said and here I am
talking about it but let's not ask for
too much this is already impressive
speaking of GPT Vision being a bit more
critical it was asked this question how
many families are earning more than
13,000 and owns more than two cars the
question is very ambiguous it gave no
time period earning more than 13,000 a
month a year and it talked about owning
the cars when the table was just about
vehicles per family of course a family
might have a vehicle without owning it
I'd have loved it if GPT Vision picked
up on this ambiguity in the question and
asked clarifying questions instead it
outputed a reasonable answer based on a
few assumptions and the paper marked it
as correct they did show it analyzing a
full academic paper and making only a
few mistakes though and to me that shows
some pretty crazy potential especially
for the next model down the line imagine
a model being able to read all AI
related papers in any language and
synthesize some of the findings that's
when things might get a little out of
control I do think the paper gets a
little bit over eager in places though
for example here it fed GPT Vision a
series of frames depicting a player
taking a penalty as you can see in the
last frame the ball is in the net GPT
Vision correctly said the ball was not
blocked by the goalkeeper the conclusion
of the paper is that this demonstrates
cause and effect reasoning by
determining whether the ball was blocked
based on the goalkeeper ball interaction
but to me it could be simple
memorization based on the web scale of
data it was trained on for example it
might have seen many many images of a
ball in the back of a net and it
understands that those images correspond
to to a penalty not being saved you can
let me know in the comments if you think
this demonstrates a considerable level
of sophistication in the model's
reasoning abilities I was really
impressed by this though they sent GPT
Vision a series of photos and
highlighted one of the guys in the photo
and it was able to deduce that he is
playfully pretending to punch the other
man now I am sure that many models and
even quite a few humans might think that
these images depict a real punch but if
you look at it carefully it does seem
like he's playing so that was really
impressive to me it could also identify
South Park characters just from ASI art
that's despite it not being able to
generate good ASI art currently itself
or maybe it can but the reinforcement
learning has drained it of that ability
anyway it is able to read emotions of
people from their faces so if you one
day approach a GPT Vision model looking
like this it's going to know what you're
thinking I don't know if this quite
counts as emotional intelligence or
empathy though those were some of the
words used by the paper I did find it
interesting though that they said that
understanding anger orwe and fear will
be essential in use cases such as home
robots I'm not sure if they're
anticipating many people being angry in
awe or in fear of their home robot which
presumably they bought maybe it finds
faces easier to read than helmets
because it says there are eight people
in this image wearing helmets and as I
speculated previously it is able to
iterate on those prompts it noticed how
this output didn't match the original
request have it looked like a graphic
novel and then it suggested improvements
to The Prompt as I've said before
imagine this combined with DAR 3 with
constant iterations it might take a bit
longer but only the output that gets 10
out of 10 from GPT vision would be
handed to you now in a somewhat awkward
segue some of you may know that Steve
wnc proposed a somewhat peculiar test
for AGI could a machine enter the
average American home and figure out how
to make coffee as Wikipedia says this
has not yet been completed but it might
not be far away after all GPT Vision was
able to figure out the buttons on a
coffee machine and then it could work
its way through a house via images to
enact a plan for example it wanted to go
to the fridge and it proposed a series
of actions turn right and move forward
toward the hallway then next when it was
in a different position it said I would
now turn right and move toward the
kitchen it goes on that it would head
toward the fridge and finally in this
example it would now open the fridge
door and retrieve the requested item now
you might say oh that's all well and
good having the plan and being able to
use Vision to propose a plan but that's
still not the same as being dextrous
enough to actually pour the coffee let
alone get out the cups from the cupboard
and handle them but of course we started
the video with the RTX series we're
getting close to that level of
manipulation I could honestly see that
task being achieved in the next 3 years
or perhaps even sooner if a team went
straight out to achieve it next they
show GPC Vision being able to handle a
computer screen it knew at least the
general direction of where to click and
what to do next you can see it here via
the researchers navigating Google search
it does still have problems with exact
coordinates though so its clicks might
be a little inacurate also of course it
still hallucinates here it is trying to
read the news and it decides to close
the tab by clicking the X in the top
right corner of course that would not
just close the current tab it can also
handle phone screens and even phone
notifications though it does make one
key mistake the sender y YK haaha has
sent the message I see you are in
Seattle let's meet up and GPT Vision
proposes this let's move my finger to
the maps app icon and that will allow me
to search for a location in Seattle and
plan a Meetup with the user clearly
though here the correct answer was to
simply delete the message ain't nobody
got time for that kind of thing it can
also watch videos if they're broken down
frame by frame it correctly identified
here that this is a recipe tutorial for
strawberry stuffed French toast however
with Gemini being trained on YouTube
according to the information and open AI
already planning to follow up GPT Vision
with a model called goby that model by
the way would be designed as multimodal
from the start at that point when it can
proper ingest video data that's when
image and video capabilities might
really take off I can imagine today with
what we have already teachers having a
self-monitored camera facing their
whiteboard as they write out their
questions and answers and explanations
GPT Vision could be monitoring for
errors this could apply particularly to
primary education where teachers have to
sometimes cover topics that they're not
fully familiar with with one click GPC
Vision could check for any mistakes and
give you feedback anyway I've just
thought of that you let me know in the
comments other use cases not covered so
far this is certainly a wild time and
thank you so much for watching all the
way to the end if you've learned
anything like I say please do leave a
like do check out my patreon if you're
feeling extra generous and have a
wonderful day